I know all about priest brutality not to
be rude but you're a white male so
anytime I see a white officer I get
scared for my life and I know you have a
body cam so yeah due to the forest my
head hit the floor so if you guys could
do a concussion test whenever this
ambulance get
here hi hi how you doing was I speeding
no you weren't speeding you don't have
your back lights on they don't turn on
they're automatic these are Auto lights
that come on so that's what's on right
now it only you don't have any way to
turn turn them on my back lights yeah so
like a lot of I break no like your tail
lights just aren't on at all so when you
break your when you break your lights
will activate but like when you're just
driving on the road regularly job these
are just Auto lights I don't really know
how to fix that okay it's not if you if
you twist it over you then my brights
are on yeah so so yeah I don't know how
to fix it I'm allowed to have my bright
saw when I'm different yeah you're not
um but there's got to be a way to have
your back lights on
um I don't know let me say can you go
ahead and put the car in par this is a
rental car this isn't even mine if you
looked at my plates already this is a
rental car okay that's fine do you have
your license on you I have a state ID
okay can you put your car in park for me
okay and do you have your ID on you I
have a state ID can you hit me in my
purse um the
[Applause]
brown no the
brown what do you guys St doing I'm
taking them home right now oh
okay I actually don't know if it's in
here but okay I can
take oh okay I got you so I just came
back okay I don't have my S ID I don't
know if you can look it up yeah I can
take down your
name it's honestly so
confusing my
car yeah I don't even this isn't my car
so I barely even know how to work it
happens it's a rental what's your first
name Jada j a h d
a and your last name Davis da a b i s
you have a middle name uh R real name
and what's your
birthday
okay all right and have you guys been
drinking no no no nobody's been drinking
at all okay she just got off at gems
okay it smells like alcohol in the car
that's why I'm asking okay so if we
don't have any alcohol in the car I know
I know I'm saying it if you have been
drinking it smells like somebody's been
drinking so that's why I'm asking okay
all right so you haven't had none of you
have had anything we at a party okay
okay all right well just give me one sec
I'm going to be right back with you
okay
okay got another
unit they were just you could tell that
they the ones in the one in the back
seats drunk for sure and I tried to
explain to the driver that was like
somebody's been drinking in this car
they're like no we haven't been
drinking so they ref or something no she
just I didn't even ask cuz they just
kept going off on they kept telling me a
bunch of stupid information that I
didn't need to know and the chick was
like oh well I don't have my ID on me so
she gave me her name and date of birth
yeah and then it's like dealer plates
she's like well this isn't my car that's
why the lights weren't
on and then she stopped like this
so okay so I'm just going to yeah I'm
just going to see if she'll uh do some
test for me
right all right so jie you said you had
nothing to drink tonight right no okay
just doing a few tests for me to see
none of us but you pulled me over for
lights isn't that a warning no it can be
a ticket I've gotten pulled over for my
lights not being on and I've sworn every
time that's a warning it's a it's a
violation so you can you can write
somebody a ticket for it like I said I
want to you know like I said I can smell
the OD of alcoholic beverage coming from
inside car me over for lights yes that's
still still a valid reason to stop you
really yeah okay I didn't know that I
thought that that was just a warning
because I've been pulled over for my
lights before and they've given me a
warning for that because I looked it up
and it said that that's not an actual
like it's not I just looked it up I just
looked it up on my phone I can show you
it just said that that's not I haven't
been to police training I don't know the
IVC or anything can I show you it just
told me show me what it is it says you
have to have two lights activated two in
the front and two in the back so my
lights didn't come on in the back I
explain that to you they weren't on what
is that like what do you mean by lights
your lights were not on in the back that
means that nobody could see you when you
were driving down the road if they were
behind you and it's all recorded on
camera so okay I guess I'm just kind of
confused but um all of us can step out
for no I just need you to step out cuz
you're the one driving
okay okay you haven't had anything to
drink right no I mean we went to a party
but I don't think that anything that we
were like containing or anything like
that has us under the influence as being
drunk okay how old are you or8 right 08
yeah yeah and you're how old 20 20 okay
all right so just come over here with me
we're going to get out of the roadway
here
um before I start do you have any
problems with your eyes or any
abnormalities or anything like that um
any uh colored contact have 2020 Vision
you think you have 2020 Vision okay all
right um so do me a favor I'm going to
just stand here real quick I'm going to
turn these lights off okay okay but no
other medical conditions that you see a
doctor for or anything like that um like
lexipro what's that depression oh okay
like anti-depressant medicine okay um
how many do you take like Xanax or
anything like that yeah I don't okay are
you taking that right now yeah when's
the last time you took it today okay
like what time um 8 a
okay okay 15 milligrams okay and you
said you you were at a party you drank a
little bit though is that what you said
okay how much did you drink not enough
to be drunk okay all right so just
really quick I'm going to run you
through some tests to make sure you're
good to drive all right okay so it's a
little bit it's kind of like a uh little
slope here so I want to do the test
right over here I just had to turn these
lights off all right the first test I'm
going to do I'm going to check your eyes
so can you take your hat off for me yeah
oh my hair's not done okay and you're
not wearing colored contacts right
anything like that like so feet heels
and Toes together but that's about it
okay all right that's fine feet heels
toes together arms down your sides just
like this okay don't do anything until I
tell you to
okay all right I'm going to check your
eyes I want you to look at the top of my
pen I want you to keep your head still
and follow the top of my pen with your
eyes and your eyes only do not move your
head do you understand okay
okay
all right and then the next part of the
test we're going to do is a walking test
okay can I put this back yep you can put
your hat back on um you don't have
problems walking NOP any like back leg
leg neck issues or anything like that
that's it okay but that doesn't prevent
you from walking like straight line walk
a little bit on my tip toes that's about
it okay all right so just again I'm
going to read a set of instructions to
you okay I'll demonstrate the test and
then I'll let you know when you can
start okay okay all right so what I want
you to do is put your right foot in
front of your left foot with your right
heel touching your left toe and your
arms down at your sides perfect hold
that position for me do not begin until
I tell you to do you understand mhm once
you begin don't stop until you've
completed the test keep your arms at
your sides at all times watch your feet
at all times and count your steps out
loud when I say begin you're going to
take nine Heel To Toe steps down the
line turn around and take nine Heel To
Toe steps back I want you to make your
turn by keeping your front foot on the
line and then use your other foot to
turn yourself around with several small
steps so I'm going to go ahead and
demonstrate that for you real quick
it'll look just like this okay just did
three for demonstration cuz if I was to
do the whole thing I would walk past you
um so you're going to do me when to stop
yep well you you'll do nine down and
back like I explained but the only thing
different from what I showed you was I
only did three steps so you'll do nine
okay can I start whenever yep you can go
and
start 5
7 8 9
okay you go ahead and turn around do
nine back
okay does this first one count as
one yes
okay
one
two okay uh the last part of the test
we're going to do is a one leg stand
okay okay hey Serena do you have a watch
on you I forgot to put mine
on don't do anything until tell I tell
you two do you understand mm when I tell
you two raise either foot of your choice
parallel to the ground approximately 6
in off the ground keep both legs
straight and hold that position while
you count allow in the following manner
1,1 10002 13 and so on until I tell you
to stop okay watch your rais foot while
you're counting and keep your arms at
your side all right you can
begin1
10023 just raise that foot up a little
bit higher for me okay thank you5 1006
1007 1008 1009 100
2011 keep going yep keep going
20123 make sure you're watching that
foot too okay5
2016 all right you could
stop okay
so since you're under the age of 21 okay
you admitted to drinking to me okay you
know you have to blow absolute zeros to
be able to drive right so I don't think
basically I said everyone in this car
has drank I did not say to you that I
have drank I said you literally just
said that you drank one in this car cuz
they wanted me to admit to you that they
had drank cuz they thought that you were
going to breiz all of us you just told
me right over here that you drank at a
party yeah but I thought you were asking
for everyone in the car I don't know my
rights if I'm being completely honest I
thought you were going to breiz all of
us no I'm going to breath Alize you
right now because okay I'm noticing
indicators of impairment and I want to
be sure that what I'm seeing from our
test are accurate okay okay so what I'm
trying to explain to you
is
you're under the age of 21 so you can't
drink and drive at
all all right jayen just walk over here
with me
okay both Illinois wesle students right
I'm not going to lie to you I'm very
nervous I just peed my pants okay is it
possible I can go to the bathroom or
just pee behind
a there's no restroom open okay okay
hang out real quick okay okay
okay Jada this is a brand new straw all
right I'm going to put this on here I'm
not going to touch the part that you're
going to use
okay all right so do me a favor all
right I'm sorry it's okay it's all right
I really have to go to the bathroom it's
okay all right can you just blow into
this until it
[Music]
clicks no hang on just a nice steady
breath okay
okay all right go ahead
all right hang on it's got to you got to
I'm sorry I'm literally going to the
bathroom right now can I I can give you
a second can I just go pee really you
can come with me you can literally come
with me I don't care but I really have
to go to the
bathroom okay I mean if if you
absolutely can't hold it we can make
that work I guess she can come with me
but I'm literally be my pants right now
okay all right she can go with you
please
okay I'm get this set up again for you
okay yeah just blow in this nice steady
breath until it clicks
okay did it click
yep we at a
0.13 okay 13 what does that mean under
Zer point that means you're over the
legal limit okay okay so you do have to
be placed under arrest okay okay put
your hand are you going to take them
home they're going to they're getting
picked up so okay okay I appreciate you
being cooperative
yep all
right so what did you say it was
sorry one3
one33 it's it's gone now I just showed
it to you a second ago you're going to
get the opportunity to blow again when
we get back to Police Department okay
can I do it right now really quick I
didn't see it I just showed it to you I
didn't look at it I'm sorry I'm sorry I
didn't see it because no we're going to
we're going to go back to police
department and then am I allowed to do
it one more time yeah we're going to get
we're going to can I do it right here
please I'd like to see it cuz I didn't
see it you're going to be able to see a
printed out version I want to see it
right now if that's okay am I allowed to
no I'm asking her is she's not in charge
she's the back Char this say traffic
stop 103 you saw it I didn't see it okay
sorry I didn't know if I was allowed to
look at it but I could have sworn that
did not say
that do you have anything in the car
that you need yeah this is a rental car
I need everything out of that car is
this your car no whose car is it a
rental whose car a rental car like C
Layman okay you can't rent a car you're
under the age of 21 so who's who rented
the car they rented the car to me that's
their fault just I don't know what their
policy is
but is your car in the shop or something
yeah oh okay so it's not an actual
rental it's just a loan like basically a
laner but it's at their shop gotcha okay
all right that makes
sense it's not from them
though there's your phone for
you I don't know they lied about their
stuff but one's wearing ' 05 and she's
not5 yes and she's not returning her mom
called a ride for them but do you want
them to get issued OBS or what yeah if
you want to ride some OBS food
drinking 95 to post for the adult female
starting
zeros is it possible you can come pee
with me again what's that I don't need a
female watch officer to watch me I don't
want to pee my pants again will you come
with me outside you can follow me we're
we're literally going to the police
department it's like a mile away I'm
peeing on your seat right now
[Music]
yes you good hang on don't get out don't
get out there's a car
coming she's peeing
again stop no get get out of the
car get out of the
car
stop six we got one taken off on us
she's trying to drive
away is your problem hey hey hey she got
back in the car get to
okay okay relax okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay ma'am okay okay okay okay
okay okay will get out I will literally
get
out fuck get out of the car get out of
the car
stop get your hand off get out of the
car you're going to get tased get out of
the car okay you're going to get fucking
okay owow ow ow
[Music]
okay where did your body kill I don't
know okay go get your body cam stand by
her she all right you good rolling your
side you okay you okay mm what's matter
here's your body cam you slam me on my
chest do you need the ambulance do you
need a rescue can you get an ambulance
yeah okay what are you hurting what's
hurting my chest your chest okay go to
your side roll to your
side I can't feel my hand hands you
can't feel your hands they numb they're
numb and
tingling you said they're numb and
tingling what else is tingling my legs
your legs can you move your legs
yes okay I'm going to have you sit up
okay my hands are my hands are numb okay
I'm going to have you sit up ready
they're numb I'm going to have you sit
up are you okay sit
up are your legs all right I can feel my
legs I can't feel my hands and my chest
hurts okay we got rescue in
rout was it worth
it I hope
so can I have my hat no I'm not allowed
to have my hat no no
why ta why we're done trying to be nice
to you but I'm asking especially after
that shit that you pulled but I'm asking
why I can't have a hat cuz I said
so it's right there I tried to be nice
to you and let you go to the bathroom
and you my hat no why what does it half
have to do with anything I put it back
in your car it's right there oh you just
grabbed it I put it back in the car but
that's going to the rental company you
realize that no it's going get to it's
getting towed you're towing my car yes
you can't take it back to the dealership
no
why cuz you're getting arrested for
DUI charges but that's not even my car
okay so how are you going to tow a car
that's not like Joe's doesn't really tow
rentals they they tow cars that are
parked in the wrong spot like they're
going to tell you basically cuz a rental
I know friends who a rental has been
told before I'm just letting you I'm
just letting you guys know let them
leave can I let can I let you know what
they're about to tell you just make sure
they don't leave all right I have
paperwork for them I'm just telling you
like Towing my car really like does not
make sense but cuz you just told me that
a fucking de a dealership a dealership
show me my car under age so that makes
me want to call them when I get out of
here how old are you you already know my
age how old are you he isn't he your
main person so why don't you ask him
20 no cuz they usually don't sell for
anybody under the age of 25 extra extra
money it's against the
law that has nothing to do with us but
you pulled me under you pulled me you
pulled me over in a rental car so you
ran my plates right I'm asking you that
you ran my plates right yeah yeah so I'm
about to call them and tell them you
just sold me a car you just ran my car
and they sold it to me underage so
that's already against the law this
isn't even my car that doesn't make
getting to how's your legs feel huh are
you injured anywhere else I said my arms
St my legs I said my chest and my arms
are numb is your chest still numb yes no
I didn't say my AR my chest was numb I
said my arms were numb yes I canot feel
them it's probably the mixture of the
cold and the fact that you slam me down
so yes well you tried to take us off on
us so I realized that your car drive so
that's on you now yes ma'am iiz police
officer so I realized that but I'm
telling you yes that they are still very
numb right anything else injured on you
cuz Russ is's going to ask what I said
is anything else injured my head hurts a
little bit probably gave me a concussion
when you slam my head your hand head
wasn't slammed on the ground yeah my
face was on the floor your head was not
slammed on the ground though no my head
hit the floor on my own on your own okay
like due to you guys slamming me on the
floor so yeah my head does
hurt if you want to do a concussion
test I threw the key in the push due to
the force my head hit the floor
thw and I know you have a body cam so
yeah due to the force my head hit the
floor so if you guys could do a
concussion test whenever this ambulance
get here it' be great to know that you
gave me a concussion right
that'd be awesome to know what's that
I'm really just trying to cooperate like
I hope you know that I know you already
looked up my file I went to uai I'm a
good kid I'm not trying I'm not trying
to play around because you tried like
literally pulling me out of the car and
I know all about priest brutality I'm
scared for my life that you're going to
shoot me that's what I'm scared about
that's why not to be rude but you're a
white male so anytime I see a white
officer I get Hella scared for my life
that's the only thing that I'm ever
worried about okay if you're questioning
that's why if you have questions that's
absolutely
why I don't want to have to worri about
being shot in the fu you can tell the
state's attorney that because they're
going to
charge yeah that's absolutely for sure
I'm going to say literally I'm scared of
white police officers okay that's fine I
feel more comfortable around this two
black officers than I do around a white
officer for sure well if and if you gave
me a con concussion you got Meed up for
sure sure okay cuz I will ooh that's
going to be interesting so when the
ambulance gets here when you walk over
there do not try to run because you will
I'm not going to try to run I'm going to
tell them exactly I will tackle you if
you run okay cuz you're white that makes
perfect sense notice how she said she
wasn't going to tackle me and she's a
female weirdo you're literally
weird hello hello sir so she resisted
arrest tried to run us over she got body
slamed to the ground excuse me and I
have scrap I don't know if you can see
my hands um if you'd like to see them
there's open AR arms there's open scars
that our chest hurts there's open scars
on my hand my head hurts and my hands
are num all three of those go for it so
you want to go to the hospital and get
checked out if you'd like I mean I know
my insurance covers it but it's up to
you it's what you'd like sure okay I
mean I suppose we can do that for you
okay um can you do all those things
though before before like treat all
those things before you take me to the
hospital you going to do it all there so
we can like take you can't do a
concussion test to the hospital you
can't do a concussion test right now not
really okay then fine I'll go with you
guys okay slamming me my head like
bounce back forward and like literally
hit the
concrete you here you can man and and I
have scrapes on my like
hand thanks for working with those yeah
thank you
guys